euromaxx highlights and here's your host
Louise Houghton hello and thank you for
joining us today we kick start our
highlights of the week with our report
on Danish Peter Thomas kluger and here's
a taste of what is coming up after that
mountain view designing homes in the
dolomite mountains recipe for success a
Berlin chef has been named cook of the
year and winter wonderland exploring
northern Sweden on snowmobiles but first
up we take a look at the latest portrait
of the Danish royal family the last one
they had painted was a hundred and
thirty years ago so there were many
eager eyes awaiting the most recent
completion Danish painted Thomas Kluger
was commissioned to do the job for years
ago and since it's been unveiled it has
caused quite a stir this is the royal
portrait at the center of the debate in
the middle of the painting is prince
christian second in line to the throne
further back to his left his father
crown prince frederik that his
grandmother queen margherita the second
who's been on the throne for over 40
years the portrait is the work of artist
Thomas kluger he had a particular vision
in mind when taking on the job and is he
in Delhi box we see Christian as a
little adult he isn't playing around
like the other children and how is he he
has a special role which is why he's
looking at us only him the Queen and
Prince Frederick that's the line of
succession
any feminine amalienborg palace in
Copenhagen is the Royal winter residence
where the portrait is now housed opinion
is sharply divided descriptions have
ranged from creepy and horrifying to
disrespectful with no shortage of
references to the addams family but
visitors to the exhibition featuring the
portrait don't seem bothered by the
criticism it's maybe a little bit dark
but no I don't think so i think it
actually portrays the future of the
royal family I think they haven't seen
in real life it's way more lighter than
I thought it was so you again hitting I
loved a bed in my living room I think
it's important to ya paint something
that fits into the time it's made so I
really think it's a good painting oh
yeah I Oh again it's appear so I
understand the world from my own
perspective and when I depict the world
it's through my eyes and not anyone
elses oh you gave me lanzo soil so I
can't pick a perspective someone else
might have been expecting lambs be true
to my work for me daba if I'm not it
becomes at best a kind of illustration
but not a work of art lashof many get
caused a the new family portrait is
joined in the royal exhibition by older
thomas krueger paintings this rendition
of crown prince frederik dates from 2009
this is the Queen's consort Prince
Henrik
and this portrait of the Queen herself
is a no frills affair no makeup and
she's sporting a knitted sweater da own
manga hoonigan portrait painting is a
centuries-old tradition there was a
phase in the modern period when it
wasn't so much in demand the paintings
were replaced by photographs but today
we're back to realist painting it's seen
in the magical realism of Thomas kluba
then it's the same in other countries to
portraiture is definitely not dead on
the contrary to any more the last time
the Danish royal family was gathered
together on canvas was in 1883 when King
Christian the ninth was on the throne
yeah any option idiomatic I considered
that painting for a long time oh yeah
friend told me I could do a lot better I
can I said I couldn't hallway August and
the 9th died ages ago and it's hard for
me to paint a dead person so Tina hi I'm
Amy not but then I thought about our
current Queen and her family with all
her grandchildren and I decided to draw
a modern picture of today's royal family
centered on the child's birth Tomas crew
guys currently at work on a new picture
in his studio which is an hour's drive
west of Copenhagen the historic
depiction of the second Schlossberg War
of 1864 is epic in its narrative and
ultra realistic in execution typically
for the artist style it boasts
meticulous detail a combination of
unsparing realism and melancholy borough
kira portraiture
Clucas new portrait of the house of
Glucksberg refers to a painting of his
own family the personal work likewise
features a dark background and a child
at the center in this case his daughter
Amalia as of his men first also said
some soup you I like painting with dark
backgrounds because I see the world as
big infinite and beyond comprehension
they never be greatly I didn't open AP
store oh wait so I prefer to isolate my
figures from this world plus the
darkness surrounding them gives the
subjects a symbolic character assumption
putra have fun will the new portrait of
the Royals features the queen and
consort plus their sons daughters-in-law
and eight grandchildren prince christian
was for when the artist embarked on the
project and ate when he completed the
colossal painting
Royals Watchers can view the historic
portrait in a Malian Bourque palace
through March the second it will then be
transferred to Queen marketers private
collection
at this time of year many people like to
head up to the mountain tops for a bit
of skiing or snowboarding there are some
people though that head up the mountains
for work Allah hell is one of the
founders of the international
architectural firm plasma studio
together with her partner's they've
overcome the challenges of working at
high altitudes and designed some much
sought-after homes what could or should
modern architecture look like when
surrounded by 3000 meter Peaks that
might steal your attention how can the
architecture come into its own without
disturbing the natural beauty around it
and how can it meet the challenge posed
by the weather to people and materials
in Sexton a village in the Italian
Dolomites architect Allah he'll set out
to find the answers her designs are a
market departure from the traditional
buildings here with their small windows
ornate decorations and lowes
saddle-shaped roofs winning over the
locals to her vision wasn't easy at
first I man fan war nor can get out
batters before any of my designs had
been built in the area it was hard for
local residents to visualize what it
would look like sale she used a fasten
vestige they were quite sceptical which
is understandable it's vashon Sam it's
kept sees the lake it's not easy to
visualize three-dimensional architecture
when it's just a drawing on a piece of
paper especially when the designs are so
different to new knoweth all mental
fresh teen but her first building which
one up in 2003 was a success the strata
hotel features large wood slats that
stretch all the way around the building
the hotel looks different from every
side that's the idea behind the design
history stands cloud will begin to us
house it isn't clear where the building
starts and where the natural
surroundings in hang the building is
embedded in the slope and it doesn't
compete with the mountains it merges
into the landscape and becomes one with
it it looks organic as though it crew
here and there's no need for it to try
to compete so see this Vietnam dooley
give ax nails with mascara student
perenco Khalil not long after the
architect built a row house right next
door and let her imagination run wild
the wood dominated design has an
aesthetic function the house also looks
like a sculpture its violence at
biscayne and experiment was it was
something of an experiment how far could
we go and what's feasible in terms of
cost and collaboration with the builders
of course in the talk of the Mack back
I'd intercept how could I make the most
of a glass roof given these weather
conditions and the snow there were so
many little obstacles I wouldn't have
trusted any other contractor with the
work fila Kleinfeld indeed I am under
and power musubi mutat ethic especially
because she built her own house on top
of an old traditional one
they're wildly different styles are part
of the design concept on the inside the
many windows suffused the atmosphere
with light but it was a challenge to
keep the place warm in winter as
temperatures here can dip down to 25
degrees below zero Celsius so who Noel
installed triple-glazed windows and good
insulation
from her home office who the hell is in
frequent contact with their partners in
London and Beijing in spite of the
distance between them the plasma studio
team are all on the same plateau when it
comes to sculptural architecture
best mate the firm successful
internationally in cities as well as in
the mountains who the hell's latest
house in Sexton features a roof and
facade made from copper it was recently
given the European copper award and it
certainly bears the plasma Studios
signature design is it's really got
sabbatical and corpulent we don't want
to just copy or duplicate natural shapes
or the shape of a cliff face formats we
want to draw upon the landscape around
us with elements in the building and
transport them into the building that's
what plasma wants to do here in the
mountains grab his plasma in the battle
who the hell's Martin architecture has
been a resounding success and she's
already mounting another Alpine project
she'll be renovating the train station
in the neighbouring village legault mio
is one of the world's two main
restaurant guides but aside from grading
establishment it also pays recognition
to the chefs in their latest book they
announced the chef of the year as
berlin-based restauranteur Daniel
Achilles his establishment has already
received many accolades but this
additional one has meant it as now
amongst the top three restaurants in the
German capital a Tatar of Jerusalem
artichokes perch in cherryville butter
crab with chicory and hibiscus Daniel
Achilles has been awarded two Michelin
stars for his cuisine three points from
fine schmekel magazine and 18 from Goma
yo restaurant guide
hi stuff his restaurant in Berlin seats
just 35 people he funded it without
investors by taking out a bank loan he
sees the fact that he's now been honored
as 2014 chef of the year as recognition
for all his work the fish assistance is
a cool of course it's really a great
honor it's clearly an immense incentive
and a boost and it also feels like a lot
of work does this is a zippy I'd like
overs his restaurants name reflects his
recipe for success rice tov translates
roughly as pure material he uses only
regional products which he buys straight
from the producers themselves in today's
delivery fresh flounder this is awful I
stand fish food I know some people might
think it's a kind of fish that doesn't
belong in old cuisine but I think it
does have a right to be there such an
outsider's I need a Science Festival
Achilles distinctive cuisine is down to
earth yet sophisticated and it's a hit
there are already 20 reservations for
today even early in the morning the
kitchen is already running at full tilt
but the tone isn't usually friendly
coins friendly but professional that's
alize honestly without trying to curry
favor he's the best boss I've ever
worked for cutting cookery is daniel's
passion and it has been since his
childhood
this camp will be fun for inhales leader
Candice who just came from inside me
everybody knows how it sometime during
your school years the question comes up
but how you want to earn your money
later on all you want to feed your
family or pay for a flat-screen TV wanta
and I decided when I was about 13 or 14
we r meets with tights and filton after
training as a chef he worked at many
well-known German gourmet restaurants
one of his mentor's was one amador known
for his molecular cuisine Spina and is
this is fun it was very exciting very
wild time I picked up how to make all
these detailed molecular dishes and it
was a very exciting and in some ways a
defining time for me finish the whole
thing didn't give his otherwise inert
ooze out there they are praising in 2009
Achilles decided to go his own way
together with his girlfriend Sabina
Damon he opened wine stuff in Berlin
it's open five days a week
his only relaxation is taking short
walks through this city center base for
Fleet is about seeking a second I like
taking these walks and of course I'd see
things that happen along the way to work
to be extremely inspiring NCAA's
pidiendo in fact Achilles finds Berlin
itself inspiring in the past 10 years
the German capital has become something
of a gourmet stronghold no other German
city has as many Michelin stars to offer
Berlin now boasts 52 * and 91 star
restaurants this culvert assist each bun
stir liban I think it's the most
exciting lively and pulsating
gastronomic seen anyone nikka segments
especially this middle segment it's
developed in Berlin where the cuisine is
just a ger a star or about to get one or
the COTS forged and the concepts are
extremely exciting work very very well
and that's what makes Berlin special
when does estas husband he knows Martin
this wall takes a quarter of an hour
then it's back to the kitchen arranging
the food sending it out in cooking more
the chef of the years working day can
last up to 14 hours Oh getting some rest
is a nice thought but right now I don't
see it as realistic with his new title
comes responsibility Daniel wants to
defend his reputation at any price but
always with down to earth cuisine whose
sophistication lies in its simplicity
now in the depths of the winter here in
Northern Europe it's not uncommon to
have snow there are however a few places
where snow is practically guaranteed
Lapland in northern Sweden is one of
them now this area has a small
population but it's always attracting
international visitors especially at
this festive time of year
dashing through the snow on an 80
horsepower snowmobile is nothing unusual
in the forests of northern Sweden
tourists can drive snowmobiles
themselves here too but their first
given a lesson German Patrick Oh Dhaka
shows them the ropes he knows just what
the holiday makers want budget for this
may be one actually not a human eye a
German tourists always want to see how
the road signs are a real hit water they
get stolen all the time that's the one
people want to hang up in the living
room and they want to get a look at a
good old red fox or arctic foxes further
in the north and there are a few wolves
too they come over from Eastern Europe
how finds it is always to most mobile
Posse here comes there's plenty of room
for wild animals the human population
density in Lapland is about to residents
per square kilometre the area is known
as Europe's last frontier in northern
Sweden temperatures of minus 20 degrees
Celsius are normal in winter and it's
dark the Sun stays below the horizon for
two weeks but you get used to it but it
cuz he was alone on these people never
been depressed at least I haven't been I
read a lot and enjoy it it's a good
opportunity to exercise my mind if it's
a bit cloudy when the Sun is below the
horizon a few sunbeams still light up
the clouds from below when the sky turns
wonderful colors lessons publish bumin
deaths taking a long walk is also a nice
way to find inner peace money should not
become in a wealth of him one attraction
you can walk to is the ice hotel it
takes more than a thousand tons of ice
and quite a bit of snow to rebuild it
every year artists from all over the
world contribute sculptures
during the Christmas season the whole
place is open and guests can spend a
chilly night there
karuna Sweden's northernmost town isn't
far away 18,000 people live here some
140 kilometers north of the Arctic
Circle among the locals are Swedes fins
and indigenous Sami who gave the place
its name in their language karuna means
ptarmigan a member of the Grouse family
Sami traditions are also reflected in
the hotel camp reponn both in its
furnishings and its cuisine there are
also regional accents in the interior
design of the hotel it's clearly Nordic
and the materials come from the area
around Corona and above all there's lots
of birch
Monique had lint introduced the regional
emphasis at Camp reponn she grew up in
corona and has been running the hotel
with her family since 2003 I am a winter
winter woman I'll have the wintertime
and winter activities and so I I think
that I like the dark time when you can
make it cozy inside a lot of fire and of
course the northern light guests can
watch for the aurora borealis in
Canberra punts Northern Lights Hall but
it's hard to predict when the colorful
stratospheric show will begin those who
don't want to wait inside can head
outside humpback on a snowmobile and
drive through the winter wonderland
now ham and cheese or banana and yogurt
a combinations of food that we're all
familiar with but two Belgian scientists
are trying to spice things up a little
through research into the compounds in
foods they found that there are many
more ingredients that would actually
complement each other even if at first
the suggestions seemed odd mousse au
chocolat is a classic dessert but what
about serving it with beets vinegar and
olive oil the testing kitchen at the
sense for taste agency has even more
daring experiments going on savor shkolu
mousse with freshly ground coffee crispy
fried onions and breakfast bacon this
combination is possible because
chocolate the onion and the coffee and
the bacon share molecules in common
flavor molecules in common this duo in
the Belgian town of Bruges is
identifying foods whose tastes fit
together and finding out why former
acclaimed chef Peter Cook eat and taste
scientist bonala whose every food
contains hundreds of chemical compounds
that create taste they've already
discovered the secrets of thousands of
ingredients we try to analyze as much as
possible new ingredients and those
ingredients we get from chefs we want to
use new ingredients or from consumers
want to use a typical local ingredients
the analyses show the aroma is present
in different foods from those findings
they've made a diagram the taste tree
shows which foods are chemically similar
and combine well
almond cookies with broccoli and clams
banana and foie gras with passion fruit
on a bed of chicken skin
beef tenderloin with mushrooms on a
cinnamon biscuit or a cocktail of beef
booya mustard gin and wheat beer the
agencies customers include cooks bar
keepers and this man a star among
belgium chocolate is dominique bassoon
he's been experimenting with unusual
ingredients the past 12 years here for
example we have a chocolate with wasabi
the Japanese spice was very hot but it's
exciting that you find it back here I
have fried onion so we take the big
Spanish onion and they slice it when mix
it with flour and then we fried it it's
really exciting for me to work with the
food pairing to see all the combinations
we can do our trained chef / xun is only
one of three chocolate ea's who've
captured aggie Michelin star
when he's whipping up new chocolate
creations dominic has soon relies on his
intuition with help from scientific food
pairing so one of the flavors we find in
the food three of that chocolate is a
mushrooms set and I think it's really
fun to make a balance between that
origin chocolate and set mushrooms so we
have probably need this is a hazelnut
praline a here when I going to put some
chocolates and now we have a dry powder
of those set mushrooms I'm going to put
it in LA and to give a little bit of
freshness and we also see on the food
pairing tree you have some sensual
pepper we're gonna put it as well the
colonies with porcini nougat are ready
dominica soon sells his chocolates all
around the globe as well as in his own
shop in his hometown Bruges
but what do the exotic chocolates taste
like to the shopper on the street
somehow strange food
bacon kind of a berry flavor crunching
you what is it
I don't know
mushroom chocolate that's interesting
new turkey and cranberry is great
together so put in chocolate we grab
yeah I am surprised but yes really good
when Allah who senpai toku Keith would
like their findings to have a positive
influence on human eating behavior we
let people discover vegetables they they
don't like an recipe they like and so
bit by bit they like to learn or they
learn to like the combination so food
pairing is a bit like life in general
what really counts is not love at first
sight but that the chemistry works well
in the end
well that is definitely a food for
thought what as the saying goes that has
brought us to the end of the show for
today though so until next time take
care of yourself and comply
you
you